[موسيقى]
هنا في حاره العقر قرر الاهالي اعاده
الحياه الى منازلهم القديمه عبر تحويلها
الى نزلا تراثيه لاستقبال السياح سواء من
داخل السلطنه او خارجها
تمتاز ولايه نزوى بوفره نزول التراثيه
وقيام سكانها بترميم البيوت القديمه
للاستفاده منها في تنشيط القطاع السياحي
الذي يعتبره الكثيرون واحد في السلطنه
خلال السنوات القليله المقبله
[موسيقى]
كان متوقع بعد عشر سنوات من الاخر ولكن ما
شاء الله كان اسرع بكثير من ما كنا ننظن
هذا كان بالنسبه لنا ايضاعم معنوي وحافظ
قوي على انه يعجل عمليات الترميم والاصلاح
في الحاره ومثل ما تشاهدون الان عمليات
التربيه المستمره وكثيره وباذن الله تعالى
في مشاريع كثيره قادمه للموقع هذا
[موسيقى]
حاره العقر التاريخيه في نزوى تضم 16 برجا
قديما بالاضافه الى اربع بوابات وصول عتيق
يصل طوله الى كيلو مترين في هذه الحاره
القديمه تم تحويل 30 بيتا تراثيا الى نزلا
فندقيه وهناك 40 بيتا تم ترميمها حتى الان
[موسيقى]
لما بدانا بهذه الخطوه الجريئه ونعنيها
هذه كلمه الجريئه لان مكلف اعاده احياء
هذه
الحوائر فكانت يعني ردت فعل ايجابيه جدا
بدات من اعاده يعني عوده السكان الاصليين
اللي كانوا يسكنوا هذه الحاره عادوا
الاقامه فيها وهذا ايضا ما جعل من الاجانب
ايضا مصدر الهام وتجربه فريده عندما يزوره
همم سلطنه عمان وبالذات نزوى فكانت افضل
تجربه انهم يقيموا في حاره اثريه قديمه
[موسيقى]
الكثير من هذه المنازل القديمه سكنها
شخصيات مهمه في تاريخ سلطنه عمان من علماء
دين ورجالات السياسه ووجها اي مجتمع ما
اعطى هذه الحاره قيمه تاريخيه لا تزال
باقيه
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه نزوى العربيه